I don't know if my marriage is gonna
survive is there anybody else involved
because like yes Lenny's dating her now
he's dating
my husband's a top plastic surgeon in
this town and I am his best creation I
love you love you too everyone loves to
underestimate me and I love to prove
everyone wrong
my husband built the perfect wife and I
built the perfect life
blink of an eye my life changed
my best friend losing my husband to
another woman
this season on the Real Housewives of
Miami
[Applause]
the difference is I bought mine
[Music]
this is like the best representation of
Miami that there is
oh my God he did not pm I birthday
travel in style darling
welcome to Baja mar it's a celebration
[Music]
police
we need to as a group learn how to put
each other up on pillars when they go
lower you go higher you know what I mean
like no no don't look at me like that
you don't tell me what to do okay you
gotta respect me period no what the [ __ ]
are you
you should apologize for this Lander
Thunder slander oh yeah come on come on
give it to me do it anymore I'm done
talking to use it out should I bring out
a little violin right all right you're
so pathetic
[Applause]
don't try don't judge me of course not
anywhere updated all said the same thing
you're very difficult your dad is
perfect and the bad one is me
you have enough filter sometimes you're
mean to me you are and I'm not mean
what is what is missing you shut down at
night I shut down at night
someone called me a week ago and told me
you were making out with the man what
she actually took a photo of it
when is it gonna stop oh come on Martina
I'm done okay I'm done my trainer
dropped me by the way because when he
hasn't training the mistress
[Music]
oh
we are fighting now
I know you want to make it work I know
you'd love to see you guys get back
together and that's not going to happen
you bring that girl anywhere near my
kids there's gonna be a huge problem do
you understand me